energy efficiency in buildings is a
major topic when we think about
economics energy systems and climate
mitigation this course explains energy
efficiency in buildings from A to Z in
this course we provide students both a
history about the achievements of
building energy efficiency and insights
into the latest developments from policy
making research academia the private
sector perspectives through sets of
in-depth conversations with leading
international experts the course content
is one of the most comprehensive ever
assembled
on building energy efficiency we hope
that students come away excited about
how building energy efficiency is a
terrific opportunity for innovation
across the domains of technology policy
and Finance and sparks excitement as
students on how they might direct their
own efforts going forward